Let's talk about
Dimensionality Reduction.
So, here,
I've got a bunch of points, okay?
And these points are in 2D, all right?
It's called kind of green and
red, but that's sort of a joke.
We're not going to worry too
much about why it was done that.
What you should notice is
that in the middle here
are these orangeish yellowish points.
Do you see why it's R and G?
Red plus green makes sort of yellowish,
or so, so
along that diagonal
it'll be kind of yellow.
I don't know who did this originally,
but it's kind of cool.
All right,
if you think about these orange points,
let's think about how
they're distributed, okay?
So, they have a have a mean sit
somewhere, and they've got a.
Set of eigenvectors, right?
They've got a co-variants
matrix that describes them.
They have a axis of least inertia and
then the next axis.
So here you're seeing the points,
the orange points are x, x bar here
is supposed to be their, their mean.
And then we've got the big eigenvector
v1 and then the smaller one v2.
And the idea is.
We can represent those orange points
by only their v1 coordinates,
plus the mean.
And what that would mean is haha.
Essentially that we're going to
think of all the orange points
as just being on that line.
And all I'm going to tell you
is where on the line they are.
And we're going to essentially ignore
the amount that they're off that line.
So we've just reduced
the dimensions from how many?
Two.
To how many?
One.
Okay, that doesn't sound like
that big a deal, nor is it.
But in higher dimensions,
this could be a huge deal.
Imagine you've got something in
10,000-dimensional space, and yes,
in just a minute, we're going to
do a 10,000-dimensional space.
If you said, well, I'm going to
represent them by one number, or
even 30, that would be a huge reduction.
So if I say, well,
what direction does it vary the most in?
And I just give you that value.
If that's good enough for
what we want to do, you've reduced
the description from being a lot of
numbers to being a much smaller number.
In fact, we can sort of express that
here algebraically in terms of just,
thinking about it,
whatever dimension x happens to be in.
So if I've got a whole bunch of data
points in some N-dimensional space,
what I want to know is
the direction of projection.
And we'll just say it's v.
All right,
that if I projected those points,
after subtracting out the mean,
that I'd have the greatest amount.
Right, the greatest variation.
And that's what that says here, right?
So take x, subtract out the mean,
dotted with the v,
summed over all the x's, take the norm.
Take the square.
Well that can be written as
an expression like this of just v
transpose Av,
where A is just this outer product.
Okay, that's the co-variants matrix
that we're, we're familiar with before.
And as we said before.
The eigenvector with
the largest eigenvalue lambda
is going to be the one that
captures that greatest variation.
In a minute I'll give you a little
argument about why it's the largest
eigenvector with the largest eigenvalue.
Or you can just take my word for it.
And, in fact, the smallest eigenvalue
would be the least amount of dimension,
so basically, what we're
going to have to do at some point
is take the eigenvectors
of this co-variance matrix.